listen guys we're one hour into this
we're not gonna fight
no one's gonna fight in here we've got
to keep it together I've got to face
facts I took a gamble and Lawrence
Gibbons
but it hasn't paid off
[Music]
when there's knives around I just can't
take a risk on someone who is so
aggressive
I lost a second please
do you regret it I've done rather well
six months ago I'd have jumped all over
him so I walked away from nothing that's
the best feeling I've done to him is to
walk away from him ignoring I suppose
I'm more pissed off that here we are so
early on and you fly off the handle I
spoke to Bonnie do you like him not I I
never wonder more [ __ ] pressure last
time cooking for the prison and you held
your own and that's what I'm more pissed
at daesil standing-room well I'm gonna
ask you to leave the course called net
shorts up to you mine tightly up to you
ma'am for me it's a missed opportunity
that's all worlds Hannah and I wish you
all the best
sorry chaps
I'm a man down but I'm certain is for
the good of the brigade
he's not team player bloody frustrating
my great shame because when he puts his
head down he can graft
[Music]
you know come on guys
now you've gone from being locked out
back in my kitchen all the knives have
been handed in but there's a serious
problem a speed peeler ie a potato
peeler in here the blade of a potato
peeler is as dangerous as a knife and in
the wrong hands could be used as a
lethal weapon
so don't manufacture tools from anything
from chair legs that might sharpen the
ends they'll find toothbrushes though
maybe a couple of razor blades on the
ends they're usually two blades and they
usually just slightly separated so when
they do cut this hard - so back up again
I give my message anyway my target for
the peeler I gave you the peeler and the
life
[Music]
no one can go no one can go to bathroom
into that spams three hours into the day
and now my kitchens in lockdown
what a disaster you know fire allows
acting the way didn't kicking off and
then they'll speak wheeler
Joey that's a blade missing that's the
kind of [ __ ] won't be in and no one
knows where is Joe we've looked all
through this kitchen but now security
been called in and have taken over
with better leaf because the peel is
gone and everyone's been searched now
rigorously because ya was where it might
end up basically the tool if it was
taken apart and reassemble in a
different fashion there it could be a
dangerous weapon